we all know Willie Nelson is a country
music icon he's written hits for Patsy
Cline and collaborated with country
music mega stars like Waylon Jennings
and Merle Haggard but his biggest claim
to fame is probably being one of
America's most legendary marijuana
smokers and he says he's pumped his
final joint in a recent interview with
San Antonio TV station KSAT Wooley
reveals he's quit the drug due to
ongoing health issues I have abused my
lungs quite a bit in the past so
breathing is a little more difficult
these days and I have to be careful
growing up in Abbott Texas the singer
admits he abused his body from young age
and is starting to take a toll on his
health mistreating myself since I was
this big you know I started out smoking
seizure bark and it went from that to
cigarettes or whatever and that almost
killed me but after being forced to
cancel several shows in August due to
breathing problems he's committed to
keeping his lungs healthy especially so
we can continue performing I don't smoke
anymore
I take better care of myself today than
I did then and despite after being the
subject of death rumors the 86 year old
doesn't care for the internet
speculation and promises he's still
healthy oh don't give me excuse me I'm
here I'm glad to be here